[Music]
this is a big one for me and i
i haven't said in a long time it's
something i said to my friend years ago
and it changed his
completely [ __ ] changed his life and
i'm so pumped i remember that
you two have inspired me to go there
mentally listen to me everybody listen
to me
do not spend time with people that don't
make you feel good
you got your perspective
i just want to be happy don't you want
to be happy
a podcast all about just what we're
feeling
anything anxieties and i wanted to ask
you
like off the just from the start of it
um how are you feeling and how how's
everything going on
your world i'm feeling uncomfortably
optimistic
and and i think that that's like an
interesting tone because i don't want to
to come across tone deaf because in the
last you know
12 hours you know i was born in this
former soviet union
and come from that kind of descent and
you know last 12 hours
my parents have told me about two of
their not necessarily best friends but
people they knew from the old country
who've literally passed from coronavirus
because they were in their 70s and
had other complications and so it feels
you know for everybody's listening i
don't want to come across
awkward or tone deaf because there's so
much difficulty going around
however i i have a funny feeling knowing
you know like this needs to be a
transparent show
and like transparently i'm optimistic as
[ __ ]
like how do you stay that way
i think it's um so there's a lot of
things that happen there one
i think that's dna like i just genuinely
think certain
you know people are born with certain
traits i think it's parenting
i think my mom definitely instilled an
uncomfortable level of
uh self-confidence in me so i feel like
i can
um i think i think i'm an old soul like
i always hung out with like 90 year olds
yeah i used to do like 12 and hanging
out yeah
like nine year olds yeah i feel you and
so
i really i it took me a long time
probably with a lot of things that have
gone on with
my internet popularity led me to like
think about my childhood more and i was
like
right like i used to go to the
playground because i'm an 80s kid you'd
go outside and play it was different
right so
you go outside and like somebody's
grandfather would be visiting them and
instead of playing basketball with my
friends i'd go sit on the bench
and shoot the [ __ ] with the grandfather
like tell me about the 50s you know like
i was very into that
and so the answer to your question is
gratitude and perspective you know i
you know and you know this i've hit you
up on dm
through the last couple years anytime i
see you post something that might make
me say wait a minute i hope
you know hope she's not too down because
my god what blessings
what kind of gifts she's been given
creatively you know she's so
[ __ ] young you know like [ __ ] those
boys who gives a [ __ ] like you know
like you know like like like i i that's
where i go though noah like i go into
like man
if like if people could put [ __ ] in
perspective like think about this
i could tell you one thing probably why
i'm so optimistic is
so many people have gotten a perspective
check like all of a sudden
you don't give a [ __ ] if you like don't
have your favorite
new outfit or or miss that concert like
when
things go basic like they are now people
go into gratitude there's somebody who
used to complain
about the barista putting in the wrong
milk in their coffee
who's now got a grandmother on a
ventilator like like you know like
[ __ ] gets corrected the [ __ ] we cry
about
gets adjusted and i would argue the
reason i'm optimistic is
i think people are gonna be more
grateful i mean when i think about the
youth that's probably listening to this
podcast when you finally get to summer
season
and you go to a [ __ ] music festival
you're gonna hug your best friend a
little tighter
you know that music on stage is gonna
sound a little better
right like that [ __ ] like alcohol you
snuck in is gonna taste a little better
right like
like it's just gonna you know i think
people are gonna be grateful
on the back end of this a little bit
more i also think people are being
thoughtful like
it also is connections look you and i
like you said have been talking for 18
months
i think on dm said in love each other's
way
and like hey you know obviously want to
meet in person but like
i would have never had i never have time
i'm busy as [ __ ] so
i know it wouldn't we wouldn't have met
and had adam
he had that meeting with you so the way
for everybody listening the way gary and
i know each other
is my manager that i've had and known
since i was he's been my manager since i
was 15 family friends since i was 12.
he had a meeting with gary and somehow i
came up in the conversation
and adam was just like i think you
really need to get connected with gary
like i just have a feeling he's going to
be such a positive light on your life
and like he has so much advice from you
which at the time was content content
content like just create create create
and that's what we did i made so much
music i went to the studio
all the time luke can tell you i have
probably
eight albums if i wanted to play
or you told adam to do that and um
i actually when when i do mental health
panels and i speak gary
and and somebody asks me a question that
i feel like is
out of my knowledge or it's about
i i'm depressed because i want to do
this in school but i don't want to tell
my family or i want to do this but my
family doesn't want to do this and i
kind of
sometimes say honestly i don't have the
answers but my friend garyvee
go check his page out and hopefully he
can help you out with this because maybe
that can be just something
he can help you out with a little more
because like that advice the stuff that
like
i've just like studied like ever since
adam told me to watch your videos like
i've been one of those people to
watch your videos and whenever i don't
really know the answers
i'm a singer i don't know business i
didn't go to college i didn't
like i like i just got my high school
diploma and i talked about
it you know so which
how do you also i want to know your
thoughts on that after but
i i feel like i just wanted you to know
like when i also feel like
people come to me and there's this
question that like
i don't i don't want to give an answer
i'm just bullshitting you know
by the way no you'll appreciate this me
neither i think one of the reasons so
many people
you know what's going on with me is
happening is i stay in my [ __ ] lane
too
like i i love it you know like i
i have you know no different than you
have the ability
to produce incredible music like i have
the ability to like feel people
but i'm also an entrepreneur so like you
know without the entrepreneurial dna i
probably have been a great
psychologist and would have loved it
right or or an anthropologist
or you know i if i loved animals a
little more and was a little not
entrepreneurial i'd probably be in the
hills of peru
studying like weird goats for 40 years
you know like i love
studying behavior um i appreciate
and again knowing enough of your fan
base of who might be listening to this
i especially gravitate towards
12 to 25 because there's so much
insecurity
and i'm all about like [ __ ] that like
like look at it this way which all of a
sudden changes
everything and and you know you can't
get that advice a lot of times from your
parents or even your
older sibling because you're like yeah
whatever you know like you know it just
is what it is like one day don't worry
about that one day you'll look back but
you're like [ __ ] you mom
like you know that's just where you're
at in your head and that third party
voice and then the other thing is i
don't pamper either
you know like one of the things that i
think i have this balance of like
honey and and and candor right like i'm
i
there's a lot of empathy and compassion
and sweetness but there's a lot of like
jersey big brother [ __ ] that's like yo
[ __ ] you
stop being like which is what i like in
your videos like i love
i love whenever people come to you and
like your tour did you call it a tour
when you go on as a tour for you yeah on
your tours
my musical language um but
but how straight up you are and like how
open you are
about like [ __ ] with people with their
parents that they might be dealing with
and lou i don't know what you were going
to say but that was something that is a
big question people come to me for
that i didn't really know the answer to
that you kind of taught me like
you know it's okay that i don't have the
answers but my friend gary does
and that's what's so great about like
being positive and like friends with
people and like actually having good
vibes towards somebody
is i don't have the answers so go check
my friend now and he'll have the answer
and it's not like this
world of like selfishness where i don't
you know
agree yes that's where where
i just like there was this time whenever
adam showed me like who gary was and who
you are and i just
really like i don't know it's like made
the biggest impact i swear and i was
that
i'm only 20. but i've had i've had
anxiety
and depression and body dysmorphia since
i was around 11 or 12.
and i kind of made that breakthrough i
would say
around i don't know a little after i met
lou which
was what uh we met probably january
of last year so probably by july
yeah i i started having a little bit of
a switch up and of course i still
you know i'm an artist artists have
their
feelings feelings and and every
everybody is entitled to having their
anxiety their depressions they're
100 it was very hard for me i had
i had only self-doubt and i
was um i couldn't really look in a
mirror i just didn't have any confidence
yeah i get it i get it i really get it
and it's like
it's crazy because a lot of times we
don't see ourselves the way the outside
world sees us
right like like and and it comes from a
lot it's just it's
chance again one thing that i always
tell people is like look
some of this is just chance chemical
[ __ ] like it's just real life it's just
like you're born
that quote-unquote way i think on the
flip side
it's about pounding your skull with
with a lot of true practical positivity
plus we all grow up differently like
you're the younger sister
of a child star like who knows what
that's doing
but it's definitely doing something
different than if it wasn't and by the
way if it wasn't
that could have been fine too like you
know i one of the things i always try to
tell people is
like that you can't blame your
circumstance because you weren't in
control i have a lot of people
that tell like literally i'll when i'm
on quote-unquote tour or when i'm doing
my videos or doing q and a shows
first person calls mad at their parents
for having no money
right next person calls mad at their
parents for having too much money
like you know next person calls parents
didn't love them a much
next person calls mad at their parents
loving them too much
like like you know there's so many
circumstances and you can take any
circumstance
and and see the good or the bad in it
and it becomes a game
of life is how you see it and it becomes
a game
of people actually caring about you and
having those conversations
to rewire perspective and what's crazy
is when the breakthrough happens it
happens like
once you once you start seeing [ __ ] a
different way and it's usually
accountability
no the number one thing that leads to
happiness is actually accountability
because when you think it's everybody
else's fault you go into victim
and you think you're helpless and you
think you're [ __ ] when you're like ah
you know what i need to [ __ ] buckle
up and i'm being a little lazy here
or i or i'm not i'm not i'm not being
grateful enough for my
uncle or whatever it might be when you
start becoming accountable
you start feeling in charge in control
and [ __ ] gets really interesting
lou you're going to say something
earlier no i was going to i was going to
tip back to the
you know my key for happiness is
appreciation and i'm talking like
i've dissected appreciation to such a
fine like i have water right now
like because i remember you know i'm the
same way i so get that bro i'm like oh
my god i woke up and nobody died that i
loved
today's the [ __ ] best meanwhile you
lose money
something gets [ __ ] up and listen i
have a thousand employees at
vaynermedia and i'm the last line of
defense it's my company i'm the ceo so
every like every person that has covet
in my company
my problem the woman that flew in from
singapore when she was five months
pregnant for a meeting
and went into premature labor and has
been stuck in america since
like my problem right like leaky roof in
our chattanooga tennessee office
my problem like it's just problems but
if you're grateful
you know how to you know it know it in
your world like
i watched some of my friends sort of
biggest artists in the world and like
the the tours not selling as well as
they wanted
and i'm like i'm like you are the
[ __ ] tour
you know like you know how awesome that
is and i'm with you on that lou like
like water is a [ __ ] blessing because
i'm on the i'm a well member for charity
water
and there's an entire [ __ ] continent
where people walk
seven miles to get clean water yeah and
that's where
i think right now i've been feeling
extremely grateful in that sense and you
know
ever since like i really met lou we've
had like some really deep level
conversations about like
what we're grateful for and stuff but i
think
everything that's going on in the world
right now especially
like um just like
i feel extra grateful like what you guys
are saying for water like whenever i'm
just driving from my house to my mom's
house to go pick up the groceries that
got
ordered and i see the homeless and i'm
like
they're not protect they're not able to
protect themselves from this virus and i
think about the people
on other continents that do have to you
know that aren't able to protect
themselves that aren't in a cleaner
environment that don't get to go home
to a home that's just themselves that
don't go to a home period that
there's so much that i also
since i can't change every single thing
i can raise awareness and i can try to
help and i can do my part
but that's where i you know with without
gratitude and without being grateful
like i feel like i'm completely helpless
to them
you know because i i feel like we take
such
little things for granted um some and
some and it's just something that this
right now like
especially like i've just like really
opened my eyes to how much like
makes me happy we we have to we hope
we we have to make compassion and
sympathy and empathy
and gratitude cool as cool as going to
coachella
and [ __ ] having yeezys like we have
to and that's
the legacy that i think you know i i
think that's the legacy of this next
generation they have the potential
to take some of these words and
genuinely make them and
and it is about making them cool it is
about making them cool
because that is the framework until
you're [ __ ] 30 for almost everybody i
have a question that
that i think a lot of my listeners will
want to
know and i'm sure you get asked this
frequently and i kind of i asked it in
the beginning kind of but i just wanted
to like touch further
because this is such a frequent question
is how does somebody that's dealing with
with mental health issues that wants to
pick
a profession that their family doesn't
want them to pick or they want
they're having anxiety about going to
college because they're not going to
have friends or
this is like all them a lot a lot of my
big yeah no i get it
i don't have the answer to what how do
you start that question with
with the with the with your parents that
when you have mental health issues or
you
you know what they're different yeah
different different profession
i think is a big big issue that that a
lot of my fans are
afraid um i get bombarded with that
especially
non-americans when you go into india and
asia
like they get so much pressure to be a
doctor lawyer
engineer here's my take and i've seen it
play out
and i've spent a lot of time on this
issue
i believe that people need to seriously
think about the following you can either
appease
and make your parents happy in the short
term
while you're unhappy and then you're
going to be 41
and resent the living [ __ ] out of your
appearance
and then you're gonna fight your parents
or
you can fight your parents now for 24 36
months
and have a great relationship forever
most kids love their parents
subconsciously or consciously so much
that they're willing to do something
they don't want to do
to make their parent happy it's actually
a very sweet
thing there's obviously some kids where
their parents are like if you don't go
do this we won't pay for college and
they're like oh [ __ ] what do i do
but a lot which i had a friend like that
growing up
yeah and like that yeah and it was very
hard for her
yeah and so like a couple things one
there's so many ways to play this let's
talk about the friend
who doesn't want to do the thing but
their parents say if you don't do this
thing we don't pay for college
on some real [ __ ] this is crazy advice
i'm like cool take the money
and [ __ ] [ __ ] i'm not kidding
that's actually the answer
like like take the [ __ ] money and and
college is a [ __ ] vacation to begin
with let's not get it twisted
college is a [ __ ] vacation i was
gonna ask you what are your thoughts on
you're talking to a dnf student who
barely got out of high school noah
like i think i think college work and
high school
and and the way education works in
america and a lot of other parts of the
world
they it works for some which is amazing
i'm super happy
for people that love high school and
love going to college and know how to
play the game and get a's and b's
and get a job great unfortunately
if you're entrepreneurial or creative
you're completely [ __ ]
i i couldn't handle school i was
homeschooled from the from
the eighth or ninth grade until i got my
diploma and
yeah no one i like consider like taking
online classes for fun
like sometimes like whatever because
you're interested in that because you're
interested yeah because you're
interested in it i was like i kind of
want to take something like
i don't know just for fun like whenever
i go on tour just to keep my brain
working why not understand
why not just take a class but that's but
that's you choosing that you're
interested in
oh i'm a little bit more interested in
balancing my checkbook now i'm more
interested in how to
you know like like like yarn work i'm
more interested
in architecture than i used to because i
went and toured
to europe and i didn't realize buildings
looked like this you're picking
not you've got to [ __ ] hit the like i
had a past two years of language
in [ __ ] high school like to graduate
i'm like i [ __ ]
suck at language like you know like so
i don't know i think i think i think
education [ __ ] with a lot of kids
almost every grown up who's 45 whether
they were successful or not
tells you it didn't [ __ ] matter
almost all of them almost all of them
yes and and i tell kids a couple things
one
it's vacation anyway so go to college
have the best time ever
take [ __ ] finance because your
parents told you to
mail it in get d's and f's or c's or
what the [ __ ] you have to get
and then when you're 22 and still young
as [ __ ] go figure out your life
and go have a good time and people don't
think that way they're like oh if i go
to college for architecture i'm gonna be
an architect like it's [ __ ] robotic
no it's not
almost nobody does what they do in
college so hey don't make it so heavy
b if that's not the case and it's more
just
pressure that they're putting on you i
think it's important to speak to change
the conversation to happiness
parents are scared most parents come
from a place of fear
so the advice they give their children
is based on defense not offense
they don't let them chase happiness they
make them chase what they think they're
gonna make money in
and it's [ __ ] up and it [ __ ] up a lot
of people and i think kids
should either go one or two rounds mail
it in
and just do it but don't give a [ __ ] or
have the tough conversation up front
know that it's gonna be shitty for 24
months but at least at 35
32 28 26 you're gonna have a great
relationship forever
because every kid that does what their
parents wanted to
and they hate that thing and then they
do that for a living
always resents their parents and the
relationship goes to [ __ ]
yeah yeah i always have a um let's see
now because of
i left school when i was 16. um i mean i
had jobs since the age of 12.
i always had a hustling mentality
because of my upbringing
my mom always encouraged me you know
just make your own money
go out there and do your thing as long
as as long as you can pay your bills
i'm good either way which is an
encouragement for and i was also a
middle child too
so the kind of forgotten one which
teaches you you know the
responsibilities but i have a spiritual
approach now where
you know back to you know in my fields
you know i firmly believe everything on
the inside
emotions thoughts all that type of stuff
creates your whole outside exterior
that's why
i have a innate ability to read people
based off of what the things they have
around them or the people they have
around them
and i'm just bringing a more spiritual
of course i get it it's context
i so agree with that lou uh back to in
your fields i think one thing that
people need to think about is getting
quiet
one thing that i've noticed noah that a
lot of people are struggling with
like if a young guy is making some money
oh he's an entrepreneur he's going to be
a [ __ ] baller
a young woman's pretty and they're
getting pop you know positive
reinforcement
i've noticed that positive reinforcement
becomes a vulnerability to negative
reinforcement
one of the things i thought you know one
of the things that i you know think
about a ton
is if you're addicted to the positive
feedback
you know the cheering on stage that you
feel i definitely know i feel like a
high when i get 10 000 people clapping
as i'm talking
uh uh people saying you're hot or you're
[ __ ] cool or whatever
then you get very vulnerable to when it
goes the other way one of the things
that's really worked for me
is silence when somebody says i mean if
you go on my instagram account right now
the latest comment is you're the goat
and the next comment is
you're full of [ __ ] right and and if
neither one of them
if neither one of them penetrate you
then you can win i see a lot of people
dismiss people
as trolls or haters when they give
negative feedback
but when somebody's saying you're
[ __ ] epic or pretty or awesome
they love that that unfortunately makes
them vulnerable to me
it's actually being silent to both and
being in your [ __ ] feels in your own
head
you love you for you you keep it quiet
as [ __ ]
that keeps you right in the middle never
too high never too low
i've seen that work for a lot of people
when they've heard that from me
say [ __ ] okay let me not get as high on
the positive comments
which has allowed them to combat the
negativity and i've noticed that a lot
in high school
and and social media dynamics when you
actually get to a place
when you don't get up on the podcast i
was gonna ask what's your advice for
that
for for people that aren't that aren't
as open to them
yeah and to the world like that don't
have
millions of followers and don't go talk
to ten thousands of people that just
that are our home and going to school
and dealing with comments from bullies
and everything
how because i answered this question i
got one time but it's kind of nice to
ask somebody else yeah yeah i got one
let's start with negative feedback and
bullies
this is why i want to make compassion
and sympathy and empathy the most
powerful words
to this next generation and this is hard
if 14 year old sarah and 16 year old
rick are listening right now
when they think of the person that's
[ __ ] with them making fun of them
spreading rumors
it's hard at that youth to have the
compassion
empathy and sympathy for the person
that's [ __ ] [ __ ] on you
but it's the truth if somebody is a
negative person in high school
[ __ ] on people spreading rumors
bullying
they're the most hurt in the whole
[ __ ] high school yeah
20 000. there's a 100 so believe it or
not
the way i think you push back on that
is actually compassion it's actually
feeling bad
for the it girl who's [ __ ] on you
because she's actually insecure as [ __ ]
cool she had a good little moment and
she looks good
but deep down she's fragile as [ __ ] and
that's why she's manifesting all this
negativity
yeah and when you can when you realize
that as the one getting picked on
you actually get happy not sad you
actually start realizing
and it's your world listen i'm 44 but
high school feels like two seconds ago i
remember every [ __ ] day of it right
like like it's your world like you're
listening to this you're like that's a
little heady
like i still got three years of this
[ __ ] high school [ __ ]
but the reality is again for little
ricky in [ __ ] high school right now
brother
i'm telling you right now you know for
for karen right now
sophomore year like i'm telling you
right now on some real [ __ ]
that person that's [ __ ] with you is
way sadder than you way sadder
yeah it may look good they might have
the hot guy boyfriend right now
but on some real [ __ ] they're [ __ ]
broken inside because
it's because people love to project the
way they feel about themselves on
someone else
to make them feel the same and and i
think it boils down to i always tell
noah this
is a section on you know uniqueness
factually spiritually we there's only
one of any of us
in the whole entire universe every
single person on the planet is the most
unique
essence that has ever existed and
there's ever going there's only ever
going to be one of you
and until we kind of understand that we
are the commanders of our own [ __ ] and
we need to take control and i understand
you know the
anxieties and you know my head used to
feel heavier than my body i used to
because it was just weighed down with so
much [ __ ]
and then i started to uncondition the
conditioning of everything i've ever
been taught
and started to realize again back to the
appreciation you know i have a warm bed
i have a roof over my head
i have a beautiful daughter who's five
months old there's so many on
my father like living in a house that i
never
i always dreamed about and you know and
by the way
and by the way lou to add to that
everybody's listening and if you're not
as blessed right now
and you work hard to get to this moment
if you're [ __ ] in this
if you're literally listening to this
while you're in a shitty [ __ ] room
where your [ __ ] parents are [ __ ]
throwing punches at each other outside
and your [ __ ] sister's anorexic and
your brothers [ __ ]
coke the [ __ ] out in that there's the
ability to be appreciative
the fact that you're even let me start
with this this is very meta
the fact that you're even listening to
this because you adore noah
means you're already thoughtful there's
a lot of [ __ ] artists to be following
i i pay attention to a ton of [ __ ] the
fact that you
are listening to this podcast already
means you're a more thoughtful kid
than the masses i believe that i
actually believe that
so a the gratitude of you of wisdom even
though you don't realize it right now
because you chose to follow noah and
chose you're making me laugh you're just
making me smile like
this is your you're great thank you
though but i actually believe it because
i really watch
and i really watch like who builds what
kind of fan bases off of what
i just know i know the kid on the other
line of this
and i'm proud of them they don't even
realize it yet their wisdom
is real they gravitated towards you
because of what you put out there
i know how that sits in popular culture
i would just tell them that like again
to build off of what lou's saying
you know when i when i [ __ ] when i
bought a 500
i bought my first car at a garage sale
for 500 bucks and i was grateful as [ __ ]
it broke down every other day but i was
grateful
and even though now i can afford any car
i want it was the fact that i was
grateful for the 500
car that actually got me to the place of
where i could afford anything i wanted
and [ __ ] things by the way real quick
the next chapter that we have to push
is happiness not money yeah making 72
000 a year and being happy as [ __ ]
is way better than making eight hundred
thousand dollars a year and being
miserable as [ __ ]
yeah because it's because people have
this notion of you know if i reach a
certain target therefore i'm going to be
happy
but if you're not happy before you reach
it you're not going to be happy when you
get it
there's always nobody now i'm i'm so ha
i already know
what's instilled in me that makes me
happy and again like back to the
spiritual thing
thoughts emotions become things i i can
surrender i can sit in my house and
surrender my emotions and my thoughts
so that people knock on my door and we
start working to get like things like
that
that's how much of a of a playing field
i'm trying to get on in terms of
almost no mind instead of thinking of
overthinking [ __ ] unthinking [ __ ]
so therefore i can just completely focus
exactly what i'm doing and
and this is the the teachings that i
bring for for noah two
is you know is we have to start living
in the now we don't have a past or a
future
everything is created now and i feel
like those were the anxieties and the
stresses and
you know even when coming on board with
noah you know there's this notion
amongst artists
that the only way they can create is in
pain and i'm trying to
create happiness just as successfully
yeah you'll be happy doing it
oh my god i mean that's that is that's
romancing
and romancing an ideology of like an
artist or ten that somebody likes
yeah and then they're like oh that's
where the good [ __ ] comes from the good
[ __ ] comes from
truth yeah absolutely and you know when
john lennon
and yoko did imagine that wasn't coming
from [ __ ] pain
it's coming from [ __ ] love yeah like
it was just true [ __ ] love and that's
why we're singing
that [ __ ] song 50 [ __ ] years later
you know what i mean like
no i i disagree that it can come from
pain
i think pain is a place that people
often can get to a place of truth
because they're in pain
i think creative comes from truth
yeah absolutely do you have
obviously i'm sure you do do you have
any advice for
um the lgbtq community who may
come out to their parents and their
parents tell them to get out of the
house because there's a lot of young
homeless youth
in in l.a alone um which my sister
started a foundation called the happy
hippie foundation and
um one of one of the things that we did
uh right right before or after christmas
is we went and we got them all hoodies
we got them all sweatpants we
food had a party and they all got to
come but it was all mostly
lgbtq community and how
can how what's your advice for somebody
that
somebody's parents who's homophobic and
just
awful as [ __ ] says get the [ __ ] out of
our house what what
what do you do when you're starting from
the ground up and you're a young kid
and and you just bared your heart out to
your parents and they just
they they just shoved you out the door
how do you
where do you start a a
recognize that it's allowed for that to
be painful like you know
every every human that is we're animals
like being rejected by your parents
because of your truth is devastating
based on a [ __ ]
[ __ ] ideology that they grew up with
you know i hate when parents use things
like i didn't grow up with this
[ __ ] adjust [ __ ] you like you know
but a recognize it's okay to be hurt
b recognize that the world is filled
with love
thank god back to gratitude thank god
your sexual preferences are far more
macro
society-wise accepted today if you were
born 100 years ago
your entire life would have been a lie
your entire life
would have been a lie you would have
been in pain until the day you died
you just started the process of pure
happiness
even though you just hit the lowest
point of your parent situation
you're about to find your community
you're about to find your friends
you're about to find a new family and oh
by the way for eighty percent of you
your parents are gonna come around too
it might not be tomorrow
it might not be six months from now so
for eight you know the reality is is
like
you actually have just been through the
hardest part actually every day
if you're listening right now when this
happened to you every day forward is
going to be better than the last day
because you're past the toughest part
which is an ultimate animal
devastation which is rejection from your
parents
80 of you are going to get them back and
they're going to apologize so that's
going to be enjoyable
and and and listen for 20
you know that's just life like like
sometimes things don't work out the way
we want but we get to choose
our our paths going forward we don't
choose our parents
we get to choose a ton and it hurts it's
the worst
and nobody should say nobody should ever
say it doesn't matter
or oh you could think like live
but recognize you're in control go find
your love
instead of dwelling that you've lost it
in the short term
from somewhere you looked for it right
and by the way that's very important
uh that love thing is important for a
lot of people right now
who also look there's a subsection of
your
community that's listening right now
that's in that world the far majority of
your community
is definitely going to resonate with the
next part which is somebody breaking up
with them and breaking their heart
right so all right so give give me the t
gary
we've all been here i'm giving it to you
how do you manage somebody breaking up
tell me it comes from desperately
understanding how lucky you are that it
happened now
i'm not kidding noah like if you
actually understand and listen it
[ __ ] hurts
especially when it's the first time like
all that [ __ ]
the first time the first time you're
deeply deeply in love like not kind of
sorta like on some fun [ __ ] but like
deep
that one hurts like crazy it happens
it's real
but a recognizing oh my god this
person this person didn't
feel the thing they needed to feel to
spend the rest of their life with me
even though that hurts
hey that has nothing to do with you
which is completely the counter
to what everybody does everybody
self-reflects if i was skinnier
if i had bigger boobs if i made more
money if i was
on the football team like everyone goes
immediately into their self
without realizing it's a hundred percent
the other person
not 99 and that there are
billions of examples of people that got
broken up with
who then got much better much happier
much deeper love from the third
relationship after that so it's really
taking
the perspective that when broken up with
it is
0.0 on you now look you might be
out of control and like drink too much
or so insecure
that you like pressured the person out
of the relationship because
every time they even talk to somebody in
the opposite sex you went on some flip
[ __ ]
like of course there's accountability
but
it's a great time to self-reflect on did
you come with positivity and love
and value or were you being selfish and
insecure
and it's a great opportunity to say look
this wasn't meant to be
and deploying optimism actual optimism
literally saying [ __ ] even though this
shoe is so hot
and so nice the next eventually i'm
gonna get somebody better
or or whatever it may be like
i hate when oh god i get these dms all
day but i'll
never get anybody better i'm like
there's eight [ __ ] billion people in
the world i promise you ricky thompson
on your high school football team's not
the hottest coolest dude you'll ever
meet you're [ __ ] 16.
you know and so like really getting
people into the proper perspective
and really not making it about
self-dwelling and beating themselves up
but realizing
it's bigger than that is a huge win i
promise
absolutely and back back to your point
gary of you know living your absolute
truth i know
previous relationships of mine i would
not live as myself
and then it would it would create a
domino effect of you know when you try
to live
yourself then there's these conflicts so
i feel like now
you know with my wife now we live
exactly as who we are and we've been
together 10 years and we're happier than
ever you know we there's no
the best they're growing walk in their
house and it's like
balance because our energies are growing
together there's no there's because you
know your energy
can propel it's like family members that
you don't like
the only reason why you still speak
again it's because
of the site or the family member so
again if they if you they won't link to
you by family
they wouldn't be in your life you know
universally
but again you know we have to realize
why why are we here we're here to feel
physical things we're here to feel
love and pain and happiness and sadness
and the difference is we
we fight against it we don't embrace it
we don't
feel it as we should and that that's
what i do now if i'm feeling upset i'm
like oh [ __ ] i'm feeling upset i
understand the feeling of it
and then i turn it into a positive why
do i feel upset and i question it and i
question it so much that it
goes away i love it lou on that point
uh i i think that's i i hope everybody
rewinds that part and listens one more
time
because that's exactly right uh and
unfortunately i have to go and facetime
somebody right now in two minutes but i
want to say this one thing that i it
just hit me during this talk
i just first of all i [ __ ] loved this
interview and i think a lot of kids are
going to benefit from it
on the show i
this is a big one for me and i i haven't
said in a long time it's something i
said to my friend years ago and it
changed his
completely [ __ ] changed his life and
i'm so pumped i remember that
you two have inspired me to go there
mentally listen to me everybody listen
to me
please do not spend do not spend time
with people that don't make you feel
good
i'm telling you right now if you're
laying in bed right now listening to
this
your best friend your boyfriend
you're like i'm telling you right now
cutting people out of your life
who do not make you feel good i mean and
when i say good
i mean safe safe
safe you know what lou it was just you
know what lou was just talking about he
feels
safe being his full self with his wife
my friend's safe
not not he takes you to the best [ __ ]
parties that you feel [ __ ] a list
that's not good that's fake good not
not they compliment you that's fake good
i mean
safe don't make jokes behind your back
when they talk to their boys
about you it's respectful when when when
your girlfriend
that she doesn't want she doesn't make
you feel like if you don't buy her [ __ ]
she's gonna break up with you
i don't mean [ __ ] fake i mean [ __ ]
real [ __ ]
real good and real good comes safe
for a lot of you it's time for you to go
back to your best friend from junior
high
they might not be the coolest kid in
high school but you felt safe when you
hung out with them
for a lot of you it's time to call an
old friend because
they felt safe we're all sitting around
in our homes right now i don't know when
you guys are airing this but i'm sure
corona is still going to be going on
go to your address book right now and go
from a to z and look at every name
and every name that made you feel safe
safe i want you to text them and say i
miss you
let's connect safety is happiness
i love that bro that was i'm literally
tearing up so let's end on that note you
can go to your facetime i love you guys
i can't wait to get out so much man
thank you thank you for being on in my
feels
i'll talk thank you again hey everybody
on youtube first of all thank you so
much so humbled for your time if you got
some value out of that
there's a plenty more where that came
from feel free to
check it out